first of all I guess I should introduce
myself I'm Stephen Simmons I work at
JPMorgan in London so I'm a Python
developer working in the commodities
trading business and we have probably
several thousand Python developers over
all in JP Morgan for much of the
investment bank the risk and trading
systems are all written in Python I work
in a small team that runs gold and
silver trading precious metals trading
and so we we sit with the traders I have
a small team in London other half of my
team is in New York and and we build
trading systems that manage hundreds of
billions of dollars worth of trades all
in Python and a part of that is using
pandas and so from the work that I did
there wanting my own pandas code to work
more efficiently I I really wanted to
dig inside pandas to see how it worked
to see what makes it made it run well
and the result is this this tutorial
session so I did a earlier version of
this talk pie data in London in May
earlier this year so the slides have
been updated with a few new slides added
from that if you have downloaded the
sample data from my github repo that is
actually a slightly larger data set than
is used on the slides here it matches
what you would see in the Jupiter
notebook if you run that Jupiter
notebook but I haven't gone through and
and changed some of the slides here that
so when you see slight differences like
that just bear that in mind so the goals
for today is to take a look at pandas
but starting from the beginning so what
Foundation of pandas built on Python
numpy for high-speed numerical
calculations plus the convenience of
data frames from our so we'll look at
look at a bit of what's underneath
pandas and then we'll go through quite a
simple straightforward example of
analyzing some sports statistics but
we'll do this in depth and so the actual
operations that we'll do will be quite
straightforward these will be the things
that you do in your everyday work using
pandas for data analysis but we will
look deep inside the operations that are
going on to see what actually happens
from the perspective of the low-level
- and lumpy objects deep inside pandas
that will help us understand why pandas
uses the syntax that it does and also
will give us some insights into which
types of operations in pandas are fast
and which ones are slow and as we'll see
there are differences of several orders
of magnitude between them the end result
from all of this is that we'll all
develop a pretty good intuition about
what is efficient pandas code that's
useful for any type of problem but
especially as you scale up problems
bigger and bigger then we really want to
make sure we're doing things the right
way so those are the goals for today we
have one hour and 20 minutes remaining
in the session so that's a fair bit of
time I that means I'm able to stop take
questions if you have them it helps to
sort of break up the monotony of me
talking all the time if you guys will
put up your hand and ask me burning
questions or you see something on the
slide
so that you don't understand what you
think is a bit strange
we may not we're not able to go down
every possible diversion that you may
want to talk about but please feel free
to raise points that you think will be
of general interest to everyone in the
room so to start we'll put pandas aside
for one moment and do a comparison
between plain Python and lumpy I guess I
should I should really ask how many
people in the room here have used pandas
before I'm getting most people have
because that's why you're here if you
haven't used pandas before then you can
treat this as a bit of a gentle
introduction to pandas and don't worry
about aspects that are that are all new
to you how many people here have used
numpy that's great
in fact which which industries to people
come from how many people here are from
financial services from I guess
pharmaceutical or no one here okay
general tech consumer tech b2b tech what
what other fields are people working in
government of course you can tell I'm
not an American okay so so most fill
people in the room have at least a basic
familiarity with the ideas of numpy and
why you might want to use it so starting
off here on the left side of the screen
is a is a way of visualizing a list of a
thousand elements in this case in Python
and the way that the objects are laid
out in Python is that the the list
itself has a portion of the list object
at the head of the list object that
tells Python what the type of the object
is so it has a pointer to it
type object it has a reference count
which keeps track of how many names in
the Python namespace are pointing to
that particular object every time
there's another reference to that object
the reference count goes up every time
those name goes out of scope gets
destroyed the reference count goes down
when the reference count goes to zero
the object can be garbage collected and
cleaned up so that's in the head of the
object also for this list we need to
know how many elements are in the list
the size of the list and then we have
pointers to all of the individual
elements in the list so here these are
the chonus the first eight first eight
numbers in each of these in turn are
normal Python objects so these have the
head with the pointer to the object type
and then a reference count for it so
that's what it looks like for Python if
we do the equivalent thing in numpy and
create an array of four byte integers
that's a thousand elements long then we
end up with a header for the for the
array as a whole which has the the same
object point of reference it has a
description that numpy uses to say what
the shape of the array is and then we
have one block of memory that has all
thousand elements in it so you can see
that's a far simpler representation of
the list than for Python the the what
we've given up is some flexibility where
these all have to be the same type so
there are all four byte integers yeah
yes so these these things down here will
show you how to introspect that that was
a great question at the right time so
what I've done is I've defined a
shortcut gso to get the size of an
object a standard Python library
function and we can now compare the
sizes of the of these basic Python
objects so a zero integer zero that's 24
bytes so that would be the eight bytes
for the pointer to the object type eight
bytes for the reference count and then
for the actual data for the for the
number itself so this is like a boxed
object if you're in Java or some other
managed language if we take an empty
list then it takes 64 bytes and then
Python will tell us that the size of the
list is nine thousand one hundred and
twelve bytes so you can go through and
say well how many bytes is that per
element what this is actually missing is
the size of the objects that are in the
array themselves and if they're all
distinct objects if they're not pointing
to the same object then we can add up
their sizes individually and we get
37,000 bytes
now at a very low level Python
identifies objects by ID
which is the memory location for it and
we can see where that is in memory so
that's that's the kind of Python sizes
of these objects we can do the same
thing in numpy and if we get the size of
the numpy array the empty array is 96
bytes so numpy needs a little bit more
information in the header of the array
about its size and so on and by
introspecting the array object itself
with item size the number of bytes we
can see how that ties together
and so the total size of the array which
is returned by one of these calls we
don't need to add up the individual
pieces we get that and that together now
if we look a little bit further inside
the array itself there's also there's
some array data which is the physical
block of memory where that stored and
and that's really the sea level view of
of an array of a thousand numbers the
shape and the strides of it is something
that we will see numpy users to figure
out where the breaks in this block of
memory are we went to retrieve
individual elements so size is one thing
but what we are really concerned about
at the end of the day is how fast these
operations are so one common thing to do
with a list of numbers is to add them up
so we can take the standard Python
function sum passing and iterable to
that and and get the the sum of it if
you're using ipython or jupiter to do
this you can use the percent time at
magic function and that will do free
trials of a certain number of runs and
figure out the average running time for
these in fact we've extended the length
of this array up to a million so that we
can get to see a bigger difference so
for a million elements the sum takes ten
milliseconds if we do the same thing
with the numpy array using the inbuilt
lumpy sum method then it's 1.2
milliseconds that's 10 times faster if
we instead make the mistake of calling
the standard Python function on the
numpy array not only is it
much slower than the plain lumpy
function which operates the tight loop
entirely in C it's also 15 times slower
than the plain Python function and the
reason for that is the plain Python sum
function expects all the objects that
it's dealing with to be proper Python
objects so the iterator over this array
needs to pull out each of these numbers
from the array form it into one of these
Python integer objects and then pass
that off to the sum function so that's a
lot more overhead and the total time for
doing this is is therefore 15 times
slower than if we were just doing plain
Python so this is one of the first
principles that we'll see over and over
again today is that the more work that
needs to be done translating between
these different representations of the
objects leads to a big a big time
penalty big speed overhead now that's
the one-dimensional case the the
two-dimensional case we can draw array
like that on the left so in in plain
Python we would have an array that
contains each element is itself an array
that has pointers to the individual
numbers on the numbers ID then we can do
this by taking say 1 array 1 dimensional
array and then saying that we want to
reshape it and then that will give us a
two-dimensional array that's actually a
really fast really streamlined operation
because this second array in light blue
is not recreating the the block of
memory for the data all that's doing is
having a slightly different structure
describing the shape of the array
but then a pointer to the same block of
memory this is something that lumpy does
really well over and over again wherever
possible it tries to reuse the same
blocks of memory so you don't get an
overhead from copying and recopying data
unnecessarily so let's let's take the
the second array we had from the
previous slide and now add on to it
third array where we have being a little
bit more sophisticated in how we're
slicing that so in this case we have an
array that starts at the third element
and then it has a step size of three so
it's going through so it would pick up
the three the six the than the one and
the four and so on if we look at that we
can we can use this a basic
informational function in dump you info
to to see information on an array and
this this tells us some interesting
things so the the shapes of the array
from the two-dimensional case you can
see that that's got that's a three by
eight array and the Strides tells numpy
how many bytes to advance to move to the
next element in that dimension so for
the two-dimensional array in order to
advance one more elements row wise we
need to advance eight elements by four
bytes or 32 bytes to move to move one
row down in the array where it's the
move one column in the array we're
moving just four bytes along as we
expect the strides for the third array
are is twelve and that's because we are
jumping over every third integer in this
array they're four bytes long three
fours or twelve
and it an easy way to also see what's
going on is this data point a line here
which shows that the first two arrays
are referring to exactly the same block
of memory the third array is referring
to a block of memory
who's referring to the same memory but
it's starting point is 12 bytes further
on so it's able to start at an offset
inside that block of memory and this is
something that pandas will use when
we're getting subsets of a data table it
will use a very similar thing right so
one of the really flexible things about
lumpy is the many different ways that it
can do indexing to pull out subsets of
the array on the previous slide we saw a
bit about how that works from referring
to the start of the memory array and the
strides and so on and this will just
this slide is just a recap of the
various syntaxes that we can use for
doing that operation so the the most
simple way of indexing from a numpy
array is just to put in a single scalar
to say that's that's the particular row
in this case that we want we want row
number one the second row and that will
pull out a slice of the array which is a
subset of that of that block of memory
we can also do more sophisticated
slicing where we say we want all of the
rows and just the first four columns and
and that gives us a block like this this
array three here and also its index in
there we can pass in an array of
integers and that will let us select
rows another way of specifying that
is with a function called take which
achieves exactly the same result and
this is something that Pender's will use
when as we'll see when we get to
indexing so pandas does indexing by
figuring out which rows in a data frame
it needs to take and then using this
take operation to retrieve them another
way of getting our indexes from a numpy
array is using boolean array so here
let's say we want to get every third
value cruz so we create an array that's
true for the elements we want to keep
and false for the ones we want not not
to keep and then we can put that in as a
subscript inside the array square
brackets and pull out those columns so
these these operations are very
low-level basic highly optimized
functions in numpy and they operate very
very fast with implementations that are
all written in C one of the other quite
surprising things for some people that
we can do is we can assign to a slice so
we can rather than just pulling out a
value here we can then use it on the
left hand side of an expression and
assign something into that so here we
can put minus 1 for all for all of the
columns now for all the values that are
multiples of 3 and that's the result
that that's really neat that can be
quite useful if you say want to zero out
some things in numpy array and we can do
exactly the same thing in Pender's so
what we've got to so far is enough of an
introduction to numpy to then be able to
launch into how our pandas works so
let's just take a moment to look at
where where
Anders came from so the origin of pandas
was in 2008 where's McKinney AQR
investment fund really wanted something
that would combine the flexibility and
user friendliness of data frames from
our but that was using Python because
python is a much much nicer syntax it's
a language that's great for prototyping
and also it's a language that has a
really really strong community lots of
great documentation examples tutorials
meetings like this that mean that it's a
great language for for businesses to
base all their workflows on now lumpy
was yep is the mic actually on or does
the mic be yep
can you hear this better now or right so
do I need to hold this up to my mouth do
okay if you can't hear just just yell
out or wave your arms or something at
the back and I'll and I'll talk a bit
louder I also have a cold at the moment
so I don't want my voice to give out
half way through okay so so the the
origins of pandas were in a QR with with
with mckinney the he wanted to combine
these three factors that would really
make his daily workers and analysts much
easier - is a great language numpy as
numerix library that a lot of people LED
especially in the early days by travis
Oliphant really optimized for the sort
of academic research
of numeric computing plus some of the
the usable features of our if we look
into the top level classes in pandas so
you do import pandas or import pandas as
PD the usual idiom and then do a PD dots
and then a tab in in ipython this will
show you what the what the top-level
classes are so I'm expecting that
everyone who's used pandas here is
familiar with data frames and series and
perhaps time series as well if if you've
been doing that's the type of work that
you do you're probably aware that
there's an index and multi index classes
and then some more esoteric types and
then as we go further down the list
you'll probably less familiar with that
but really there's some three the
relatively small number of high-level
classes that we use in addition inside
numbers or inside pandas there's a whole
lot more specialized objects that
actually make it work efficiently things
like block managers join units walks and
things like that so who was heard of a
block manager one well yes
okay so we will talk a bit about block
managers and so at the end of this talk
everyone will be putting their hands up
about that because block managers are
actually what bridges the gap between
numpy and pandas to make it all work and
out to think it's in one sense it's
testament to the user friendliness of
pandas that have a room full of people
using it and they don't know a black box
managers but also it's illustrates
something else and that is that pandas
appears simple at the surface but once
you get underneath that there's actually
a lot there so if you look at the number
of methods on a data frame now there's a
lot so there's four twenty five maybe
four twenty six in the latest version of
numpy the came out five days ago in
North Point nineteen point zero so
there's a lot of stuff here and in
general you won't use most of those but
one thing the principle of pandas they
try to make it easy so that everything
is in the main namespace you can hit tab
at the repple to get completions for
things that's great if you know what you
want but you can very easily find
yourself in a morass of hundreds of
different types of methods some of them
lower-level some of them a higher level
some of them are older ways of doing
things some of them and newer ways of
doing things and it can be quite
confusing sometimes as to what's the
right way to move forward one of the
results of this is that using pandas
often feels like it has a very bumpy
learning curve so when you start off
it's just like using Excel or anything
else that you might have used it reuses
a lot of the common Python syntaxes so
it feels familiar it's really easy to
get started
but then as you get a little bit further
into it some of the operations that you
expect you should be able to do a little
bit hard to figure out and you're left
scratching your head saying how am I
supposed to join these data frames
together why am I getting a set with
copy warning where is this coming from
and at least for me it felt a bit like
the learning curve was like this I
thought I knew how pandas worked and
then I tried to do a little bit more and
I felt it left me feeling really dumb
because these things just didn't work
and then you look a little bit more into
it and you you something clicks you
figure that out maybe you figure out
more about how indexes work and then you
can take thank you and ah that's way
better so you then figure out how
indexes work and then you feel like your
mastery has moved up to the next level
and then you start trying to do some
things that are pushing against memory
limits or speed limits or things like
that and then you feel like you need to
take a couple of steps back and look
deeper inside so one of the aims of
today's tutorial is to help give you a
roadmap for navigating where these bumps
are now I don't expect that you will
remember every little detail that we
follow here but it should give you the
indications of where to go back to the
pandas documentation look to the pandas
source code and go into things in a
little bit more detail to help get you
over these hurdles
okay so now we're about to embark on our
pandas analysis so the steps listed here
are generic steps for doing any type of
analytical tasks with pandas the basic
steps in our raw data and load it into a
data frame so we can look at it play
around with it see really what's what's
there that normally means would want to
reformat columns add indexes to it for
looking things up and so on and then
take subsets of the data frame do maybe
some more specialized analysis or checks
on that and then produce some summary
statistics by aggregating by different
index fields sub totaling things with
we've grouped by and then doing some
final processing for displaying results
so these are fairly basic steps fairly
generic we're trying to keep this simple
because the insight will come from
what's happening underneath that now the
the starting point here is going to be
Australian rules football I guess there
are no Australians in the room other
than me no fantastic
has anyone ever seen Australian rules
football on TV okay so a couple okay now
I know
definitely not so Australian rules
football started in the the state of
Victoria which is one of the southern
states in Australia
in the late 1800s and in Melbourne the
first proper competition started in 1897
and so the the competition in Australia
now is back then it was called the
Victorian Football League VFL now it's
called the Australian Football League
and AFL has teams all around Australia
and they say in in Melbourne especially
the 40 AFL is is like the main religion
there the whole to give you an idea of
how important it is last Saturday was
the grand final for the 2016 series and
so the state of Victoria had a public
holiday on the Thursday before so there
was a parade of all the players and then
everyone took a Friday off as well so
it's a slightly sports mad country and
Australian rules football is one of the
yeah most fanatical things about it
if you load this data set the sample
data set you'll see it looks like this
and one of the that so this is a listing
of all of the games that have ever been
played since the start of the
tournament's in 1897 one curious aspect
is the scores here and the schools are
made up of three numbers the first
number is a number of goals which is
worth 6 points the second number is
something called behind which is really
something that's not quite a goal and
I'll show you
a little video on that but the total is
the total number of points so this is
what Ozzy rules football looks like it's
played with I guess a ball that's
oval-shaped a bit like a football what
you would call the football and but the
players you know they're not wearing
what so the players are not wearing body
armor or anything like that the whole
aim of the game is to run fast to jump
high
catch the ball if you catch the ball on
the fall you can then take a free-kick
and the aim is to kick the ball through
the goals here so there are four ball
posts if you get it through the middle
two you get six points and that's a goal
if your aim is not so good and you kick
it
you miss the middle but kick it between
here or here then that's a behind and
you get one point for that this is video
from the Melbourne Cricket Ground which
is the the playing surface for football
there it's about 120 yards long that's
pretty large and it can fit a hundred
and ten thousand spectators now let's
see this may play with sound
it may not ok so there's no sound here
but it shows how people run and catch
the ball and they can hand pass it by
punching it and then kick it and he's
just kicked at 50 meters and got it
through the two goals the score was one
point difference and it was just before
the end of the game so everyone's gone
mad
so that's that's what football looks
like that's what I call football
sometimes 40 or AFL
so that's what we're talking about here
so that's the total score in points yeah
so the game has four quarters so that's
the end of the fourth quarter the last
seconds so each quarter is half an hour
long let's try and get this back right
try and get rid of this border okay yes
jump through okay so the end result of
all of the analysis we do or from the
player's perspective the end results of
season of playing footie games is a
premiership ladder and here the teams
ranked by the number of wins or by the
number of points they've they've scored
and you get four points for a win two
for a draw and none for a loss
and then if teams are equal on points
then they get ranked by percentage which
is the ratio of points as in six six
points for a goal one four behind the
ratio of points for and against so what
we're going to do over the next 40
minutes or so is to rebuild this table
from the raw data there so the first
step in our analysis is is loading this
raw data into panda's data frame and one
of the many things that Enders makes
easy is loading data in so here this
this is totally freeform text
well totally freeform text and here we
can load it in with
just one line of code there's I'm
guessing most people have not used a
read in CSV data quite like this with
these these number of odd features to it
there's a couple of things you can put
in here skip a number of rows at the
start to take out that heading at the
top the separator between columns can be
a regular expression if the engine that
it uses is Python and we can also do
things to our dates properly into into
Python objects all in one go so one line
of code that will read in our data frame
and if we display it from repple like
ipython we'll see something like this so
the different portions of the panda's
data frame i've highlighted in different
colors the on the far left in red is the
index and you get that by doing dot
index on the data frame and here it's a
special type of object called a range
index and this is a bit like specifying
in in python a range with a start of
stop and a step exactly the same thing
here this whole index with 14,000
elements can be represented by just
three numbers and a lot of the time we
don't actually need to materialize index
with all of these individual objects we
all pandas can just use that directly
along the top in yellow is the columns
which is pandas index objects which has
the names of the columns the game num
the date the round home team and so on
now numpy represent if we go to numpy
num be represented the types of all
Jackson lumpy arrays by d-type a data
type and pandas does the same thing and
we can get the data types of all of the
columns of the array here and also get
the values of data in the array which is
in green if we look at the values of the
array then what we get back is a numpy
array where the different columns are of
different types so it like a rec array
so that that that seems quite
straightforward but that's not actually
what how it's how it's some stored under
the hood yeah Oh down I know seconds no
anything something think things like
that are kind of I think best answered
by going off to pendants documentation
and looking at that it's because you
know there's a million features of
pandas and I really want to focus on
those structural things here yes now
you're right that it is storing it as a
I guess it's an 8 byte structure there
so what are some of the ways that we
what can select different columns over
the data frame so if we took this the
block in green that we got from doing
dot values that took 35 milliseconds
which for data set this big is not
actually too
terribly impressive whereas if we get a
dataframe with two columns here with the
round and the home score the two that
are highlighted in blue that actually
takes half a millisecond so that's um
seventy times faster so that looks a bit
mystifying isn't it such a big speed
difference then if we got those same two
columns but we got them as individual
columns then actually they take just two
microseconds each which is amazingly
fast that's 250 times faster than the
previous one so that suggests there's
something very different going on here
the last two examples here have the
first one is getting a series from a
column and then the second example is
getting a data frame from the column and
that takes 240 times more so there's
quite a big speed differential here and
so there's obviously something very
different going on underneath to account
for that and what's going on behind the
scenes is this mysterious block manager
object so if we take a data frame and we
do dot locks on it we get back
dictionary where the keys of this
dictionary here are all the different
data types then the data frame if the
values of them are then other data
frames that have all columns of that one
type if we get the block manager which
is an underscore data attribute of the
data frame and then look at the blocks
in that block manager we see that we
have an integer block a date/time block
and an object block so that these the
object block has all of the strings
so what actually Pender's has done
underneath is taken a heterogeneous data
frame where the columns are of different
types and it's partition them into
subsets of columns that all have the
same type and then those subsets of
columns can be represented by one numpy
array and that one numpy array is now
homogeneous and it has just one type and
so the types of indexing and selecting
selection operations that we saw near
the start of the talk we can do those on
that individual block manager block now
their various mappings between the
numbers of the blocks and the columns
come in they're shown in the next one
here and by doing some timing we can see
the retrieving the different values from
from these blocks is closely aligned
with what's going on here so just back
to this slide here
so you can see that where we've pulled
out a no sorry
I'll move on instead okay so one of the
other aspects of using the the block
manager to retrieve individual columns
and this is why getting the series was
so fast was that there is a whole lot of
inbuilt caching going on so that if you
get a series over and over again it's
already cached the reference to that and
it can just return that immediately
rather than figuring out again which
columns of the table with is and so on
we can see that by getting the data
frame in the repple the square brackets
is really the
double underscore getitem method and if
we do in ipython or or jupiter a double
question mark and then hit enter that
will then show us the source code so one
one really useful principle with pandas
is if you don't understand what it's
trying to do then rather than calling
the function to do it put in the double
question marks and hit enter and then
you'll see straight away what the code
is is is being called so if you do that
you'll get a code listing for the gate
item function and we can then trace
through the layers of calls that it's
doing the gate item column and then look
at the values of that and that will then
show that there's in red down here a get
item cache so this is one way that numpy
sorry that the pandas uses to to save
redoing the same operations over and
over again to make your calculations
fast and we can see see how this works
if we timing just getting a series from
from our data frame the time-it function
in ipython realizes that the first run
is relatively slow and subsequent
subsequent runs are much much quicker
and so it says are suspect some caching
is going on and we can look at the cache
and see what's in there if we run this
again we don't get that warning because
it's already cached so it if we want to
select some columns there's two
different ways that we can do that in
this example here so getting the the
and the round weave because we've got
multiple columns in there it returns
data frame and that takes 500
microseconds and that operation of
retrieving that data frame is actually
two individual steps and the the first
step can be thought of as getting an
indexer for those columns and in pandas
terminology an indexer is just an array
with integer values that tells us which
rows or columns to come back so that
does the lookup - to translate these
values into offsets or indexes into into
the underlying data table and then the
second step is to use that though these
index are with take function and we saw
in numpy that there's a take function
that's used to pull back individual
columns and so that's that's what pandas
uses it can be very a little bit
confusing here because we're talking
about index objects we're talking about
an indexer there's an array of integers
and we could talk about an index into
the rows and columns so it could be a
little bit confusing but specifically an
indexer is an array of integers saying
which items we need to take so the
result of that is a little data frame
like this when we are selecting rows
from a data frame relatively a very
similar thing goes on in this case it
was specifying rows
14800 37 to 39 now this is treated like
in in python where the ending point is
excluded this little note here says that
if you use eye lock
function then you'll get it you'll
include the end one the timing for this
is if we pull this out we can do it in
120 microseconds which is which is
pretty fast one thing to see is that the
sub data frame that we get from the blue
section here if we look at the the
columns on it and check whether how that
relates to the columns on the original
data frame using the is operator that
comes back is true saying it's the same
object so what pandas has been able to
do is they've been able to take a new
data frame and stick an existing column
index on it so that doesn't need to be
rebuilt from scratch it just the
reference to that can be added and so
that's that's relatively quick the row
index for our new smaller data frame is
also a range index object and this is it
knows that it has a new start and a stop
so it's been able to build that really
quickly from the other one so when we're
thinking about what this the selection
of selection operations are they can be
boiled down to looking up in the index a
row index or a column index to see which
rows or columns that we need and then an
operation to actually retrieve the the
right rows from the underlying numpy
data so here is here is some timings for
doing different aspects of that so these
examples here that are operating on bot
values the dot values gives numpy array
so so this is what you get at lumpy
speed and then the extra pandas
operation needs to add a little bit more
to do the sort of decoration around the
the rows and the columns so that's um
that's how the basic selection of rows
and columns works the next step that we
would want to do for our analysis is to
reformat columns and add some indexes to
the rows so the the original data was
from the perspective of a game that
involved two teams we want to get a set
of data that is now from the perspective
of teams so each one of these games
needs to be split into two rows and we
can do that by getting results from the
perspective of a home team and an away
team and one really nifty feature of
recent pandas is that they can split a
string into multiple columns straight
into a data frame on a regular
expression and so the the home schools
and the away schools section there is is
doing that in two columns that are named
G B and F for the goals behinds and then
the points for and then because we've
got Home & Away teams the points for one
team is equivalent to the away points
for the other team
within this gives us two different data
frames that we can then stack together
with concat and the and then we can put
index on that the end result of doing
that is a data frame that looks like
this so let's just look a little bit
more into what indexes are and how
pandas treats them so here is an example
of an index that is not unique because
it repeats the value but it is monotonic
because they're in order and so if we
use the index to find out what locations
and element is that
for an a there's just one of them so we
get a scalar zero back and if there are
multiple locations for it then we can
get a slice this second case here the
index is no longer monotonic and so when
we ask the index to give the locations
back it gives us a boolean array with
trues and falses with throughs where the
matching elements are and if you think
back to how indexing in numpy worked the
last second last example we had had
indexing with a boolean array and that's
what pandas would use this is how pandas
constructs that array to say which rows
or columns to select well it depends on
it depends on the situation
so you know it tries and as if you look
in the code impendence has a lot of
special cases for handling the different
situations if it can do things with a
slice the simplest possible way it will
do it with that if it needs to specify
individual columns or rows then it will
specify those if it needs to have
something that will cover the hole with
a boolean then it will use that so one
of the other uses of indexes in in
pandas and this is really what it
brought over from from data frames in
our wares using indexes to align series
and the way that this works is here are
two series where their indexes are
slightly different if we add them up
then the down the bottom there you'll
see that we've got some nan values where
there are some gaps where the addition
didn't work and also it seems we've
turned into floating-point numbers so
what's actually going on here is is
shown on this side is that in order to
add these
- series together they need to have
compatible indexes and the indexes are
made compatible by first of all taking a
union of the indexes and then re
indexing the series and that expands out
the series or contracts that leaving the
values we need putting in an an where
there are any gaps now because man is a
floating point value our array can no
longer stay as integers and it has to
get promoted to floating point so if
you're doing some kind of an addition of
series or something like that in pandas
and you suddenly see floating point
numbers have popped up where you didn't
expect them it's because the index
expansion in order to match them up has
inserted nan values and then so that
some promoted your integers to floats
another thing that indexes are use for
for joining and merging if you have a an
old version of the the slides or one
from before earlier this morning from my
repo this slide won't be being here I
added this this first thing this morning
so if we have two data frames and we
want to join them there's a simple join
operation the data frame join and we can
do an inner join or a left join and you
can see if we do a left join that that's
stunning that there are some values from
the left index that are not there in the
right index so that's had to open up
effectively open up a gap in the
right-hand data frame when nan values
have been inserted
they've been promoted from int to floats
so that we can store an an so that all
columns have the same type and so that's
what that's what the join looks like
that join is actually equivalent to
using this function called merge which
has a whole lot of special cases of how
to do these for
different situations for data frames and
series etc etc the actual code for doing
this is in pandas ours at panda school
stop merge and it uses a low-level
operation called a merge operation and
that will in in the middle of it builds
this this object called merge operation
then you call get result on it and the
first thing it does is to figure out how
the indexes of the left data frame and
the right data frame need to be
manipulated and then what's the final
index join index that gets returned and
then it does some magic about using
those to concatenate the data from the
block managers within those data tables
and put it all together so these are the
infamous block managers coming out again
the UM the left index R and the right
index are shown on the bottom left there
and the values that are minus 1
that's when land values will be inserted
so now for our data frame we've added
indexes to it and we've actually ended
up with multiple columns in that index
and that's called a multi index and some
of the the multi index has is here if we
do school start index the the multi
index has three parts to it
the first is names which is the the
names of the columns of the index the
next is the levels which are the unique
values in each of those columns of the
index and then the third of labels which
are integers that are used to as indexes
into each of these levels and so when
Pender's is doing operations involving
this index involving multi
DEQ's it first translates these these
different levels into numerical values
which it then uses to take back the
different rows and and and that's how we
end up selecting rows using a multi
index the values part here this is a
plain numpy array these are all integers
now and so bringing back score values
this is this takes five microseconds
whereas at the start when we had
heterogeneous data frame where the
columns with different types that took
35 milliseconds so this is seven
thousand times faster because the data
is just there it doesn't need to be
reassembled on the fly we can look at
what the the data blocks are from within
the block manager inside the data frame
these are all integers so we have just
one block manager that holds integers
now what we want to do for building our
ladder for the championship is to select
some subsets of rows and we want to take
results just from 2016 and we wanted to
take just results from the round-robin
tournament which have round names
beginning with our we have other ones so
that the grand final semi final and so
on GF and SF but by selecting ones that
begin with our we just get the normal
games so so that's the type of selection
operation that we would like to do here
are five different ways of doing it one
way that a lot of people that are new to
pandas use is to use group by to get all
of one sort of the same say the same
date and the same realm of tournament
together decide whether they want to
keep them and then use concat
put them back together as a data frame
if we if we do that that takes not 0.8
seconds 820 milliseconds this approach
here is it takes 1.2 seconds so this
produces a array of the rows that we
want to keep this this one is 8
milliseconds so that's a hundred times
faster which is looking up things
directly from the index whereas this is
doing an iteration over the table if we
do an iteration over the table then
pandas pulls back ER creates a new
series for every row in the table so for
the first row it creates a table for the
second row it creates a table for the
third one but for the second row it
creates a series for the third row it
creates another series that's a lot of
overhead that it's having to do where
really we end up not using that so
that's very inefficient operating on the
index directly is is a lot faster and
here is an another way that we could do
it where get the level values for a
particular level match that get the
level values for the round so these are
each arrays that are end up being
bullying's and them together and then
pull out the the rows that match where
that's true so that's pretty quick if
you have a recent version of pandas you
can actually do it directly like this
and and that's the fastest of all
there's a note on the on the Left saying
that there's a bug in pandas naught
point eighteen point zero where this
doesn't work quite correctly but that's
all been fixed in naught point eighteen
point one which
out on the 6th of May and in or point 19
which was out last Saturday is that a
question okay so so this is this is just
like a start and an end so from from a
value to the next value so yeah yeah so
so it it so Pender's we'll check the
types here we'll say what's underlying
here is date time object or a numpy date
time object when matching on a string it
will then figure out what these strings
mean in the the numpy date time terms
and then use that for the upper and
lower bounds to restrict that if you if
you give it if you give it the year 2016
that doesn't work as if you give the
year as a number it doesn't work I mean
I have to say putting this to go you
know these look quite straightforward
once they're presented to you but to
actually figure out exactly the right
syntax for these there there's not
necessarily one single place to go with
good examples for exactly what you want
to do and Stack Overflow can often be a
bit misleading because you see something
that several years old so really I find
and this is one of my you know one of
the other things that means for me the
pandas learning curve is a bit like this
is that seems to involve a lot of trial
and error at the command line trying to
get it exactly right
with respect to the JPMorgan how do you
manage that
well don't be Morgan the way we manage
anything for everyone is just throw them
in at the deep end and they have to cope
we have thousands of developers working
in a code base that I think has 300,000
source files that's probably 20 million
lines of code we've live pushes to
production globally happening 24/7 and
and it seems to work most of the time I
don't know one from David Morgan is
listening it actually works really well
okay so with the with the numpy example
for indexing the very last bit on the
indexing slide showed that we could
assign values with a sub with a sub set
of an array on the on the left hand side
here we can do the same thing in in
pandas so we could actually take say
select the selection of an array that we
want to zero out we could we could set
the zero to it and then you know this
whole chunk of the array is gone to zero
so that can be quite useful if you are
trying to initialize or nuke out portion
of a data frame that you don't want now
will actually move on a bit I'll just
skip over here okay so the next thing we
want to do is add some calculated
columns to our data frame and one if we
take the subset of the data frame and
then just try and add a new column to it
we get a warning saying that we have a
setting with copy warning and what is
actually happening behind the scenes
here is that our data frame Y is
referring
back to the original underlying lumpy
data in the scores data frame pandas is
worried that we're updating Y heading a
new column to Y or changing values in Y
but we may not be aware that this would
change things in the underlying data
table data frame in schools so we get a
warning for that and the the way around
that is actually to make a copy make an
explicit copy so we get our own
underlying data to data array to work
from now inserting a column is really
really fast
the timings for doing that are here and
the reason is that every time we add a
column it will create a new block
manager and that breaks the rule that
says a block manager has all of the
columns of a certain type because if we
added that into that new column into an
existing block manager that would mean a
whole lot of copying of data so Pender's
presumes that you'll probably want to
add several columns at the same time and
so it defers consolidating them until
you run a function on your data frame
that actually needs them to be
consolidated and and so then it will do
that behind the scenes and so this flag
the data is consolidated would be true
and it actually has just one block in
the in the block manager rather than two
there so inserting columns is really
fast and this is this is one of the
things you know that that you might
think is relatively slow so you try and
deferred but actually pulling out a
series from a data frame is blindingly
fast because everything is cached adding
a column to a data frame is blindingly
fast until you start to do calculations
on it and then then it all gets
consolidated now to complete our ladder
for the
the schools here we needed to add
columns for the number of games one
drawn and lost and so we have this
column P for the number of games played
for the number of games won we can do
that by comparing the goals for and
against and we could also a number of
different ways of doing it so the wins
shown there for the losses we can use an
avowal function like that to get that if
we do this we end up with some things
that are not quite the data types that
we we would expect and and the reason
for that is the this expression for the
wins it ended up as a boolean I guess if
we thought about it we would say yeah we
get boolean rather than an int so we
need to force that back to an int and
then for finding the draws
most of them sorry this this one with a
lock is the first bit in selecting which
rows we want to select which is where
the points for and against are the same
so that's where there's a draw and we
want to stick that in a column called D
and when we put a one there the reason
why that didn't work out is that where
there were zeroes will get Nan's so we
we want to put the fill in a at the end
of that and that converts an ends to
zeros here but because we had Nan's
there those end up as floating point as
we saw earlier when thumb missing values
get promoted to floats so we need to
force that back to an integer and then
we end up with with the table that we
like and again you can see as we add the
columns we have the different data block
and they can then get consolidated so
now we can aggregate things with group
by and group by a team and do the sum
now in one of the examples earlier we're
doing concat with a group by and that
was really slow that took naught 0.8
seconds here's a similar example added
in a second level for Venu to make the
difference a little bit more apparent
and here this is 233 milliseconds again
because what this is doing is it's
building a whole lot of sub data frames
and then merging them again if all we're
going to do is to call a function like
some on it or something like that then
actually Pender's is smart enough to not
have to rebuild all the individual data
frames within it and it can just do that
using low-level internal operations by
figuring out which rows are in scope and
so that ends up being 50 times faster so
so that's a good thing to know here's a
description of the the internals of it
where it pulls out an object called a
grouper and figures out the groups and
then the indexes on all of that now the
last thing we want to do is to add some
the points and the percentages to new
columns and then also sort this so that
it has the the best team at the top if
you do this with the in the number that
Jupiter notebook in my github repo then
that is through to the end of the season
so it will show the the top teams at the
end of the season now just do a bit of
tidying up the formatting and adding a
rank to it and the end result that we
get here is exactly the same as the
results from the Australian Football
League website
in May so we've achieved our end result
here's the code that does that and along
the way we've seen a number of aspects
of Pender's so what we've seen is that
Pender's is a really powerful way of
doing data analysis but it tries really
hard to be optimized you can give it a
simple expression and it will figure out
how to do that if you structure your
data so that it ends up being done in an
inefficient way then it can take a
thousand times more than if you do it in
the most efficient way and the key to
understanding why that is happening is
from looking at the the court hood one
of the best ways to build this kind of
intuition for yourself is to explore
data frame objects and these type of
operations in ipython or in a jupiter
notebook using the double question mark
to pull down see the source code that's
being executed and using time at all
profiling functions to do that also
don't be afraid to scale up problems
that you might do on you know in a small
laptop to quite large problems by being
smart about how pandas represents data
you can actually do quite large problems
on one machine before you scale out to
something that uses you know maybe desk
or or a system like that for doing
something in a distributed way in most
of all don't be scared to look inside
the pandas code trial and error can be
very frustrating at the command line you
can easily spend half a day getting very
frustrated when just a quick look inside
the code will help you see what path
things are taking if you want to play
around with some of the ideas from this
tutorial here are some things that you
may like to do
that's the end so thank you very much I
guess we have about four minutes left so
if there any questions feel free to ask
or maybe come up and talk to me
one-on-one and everyone else go off and
enjoy the rest of pie data thank you